the ego also helps us achieve our goals
as well so there's also something nice
about our conscientious ability to set a
goal and to be happy along the journey
I'll get to that goal
no no ego ego prevents you from
achieving your goals first of all define
what your goals are if your goals are to
be happy then ego is [ __ ] it up
completely right because you'll never be
happy chasing an ego because people are
busy chasing their own egos so they're
not what do you use the set of goal then
is 1 billion happy about goal it's a
great goal but huh but what do you use
if not the ego what is B what are you
use to set it so this is the most
interesting discovery I you know for
myself and for my children and for
everyone I start I worked with for the
last 11 years we have a tendency to be
motivated by the negative this is the
way our parents you know raised us I'm
stick I just imagine a stick yes school
school you score an A in school or score
AB or pass the test for no reason other
than you're trying to avoid problems
here right you stand in the street and
protest against whatever it is that
you're you know you're you're against
you know why because of hate or anger or
you know disgust or whatever that is
Robin Hanson wrote a great book about
this as well yeah we we we vote to show
our community that yeah we're with you
absolutely yeah have you ever tried to
be motivated by the positive oh my god
it's a very different the positive could
be the carrot but that's also a little
bit of very self centered and focused
right like providing value to society so
so so I could stand in in a in a public
square and protests because of anger for
what's happening in Syria and the people
that are dying or I could stand in the
same place and protest for compassion
for the people who are suffering so much
right which of them would produce a
better result do you think
if I'm angry I will waste so much time
and effort and tension on my anger and
once I release that anger it's over if
it's compassion I'm actually driven with
you know with a peaceful approach to
actually fixing the problem I have
nothing to release I just want the
people to be better
remember Gandhi right was Gandhi the
motivated by hate or motivated by
compassion by you know by peacefulness
by the right things huh yeah if I want
to motivate myself do I have to motivate
myself by you know telling myself that
I'm a horrible person
do I have to feel that I'm bad to become
better or can I actually feel wonderful
about what I've tried to achieve so far
and still want to be better can I love
me yeah and still want to be better
that's ours are they controversy no so
so if we start to learn this one little
trick of I want to be motivated by the
positive right and and there is so much
positive we can have in the world right
there you're my positive is I'm trying
to make by the way a billion happy it's
just a directional target and you hit
ten million and then you upgrade it to 1
billion yeah but but but you know what
my target is right now to make you guys
happy if that happens great great day
when tomorrow happens we'll see how many
people would show up right that it but
but that's a wonderful measure of
success it's a wonderful measure of
success